the day after multiple russian missiles
hit targets in levee in the west of
ukraine
president vladimir zelinski demanded
world leaders give his country more
weapons
his tone
taunting at times
it is planes for ukraine it is tanks for
our state it is missile defenses it is
anti-ship weapons that's what our
partners have just gathering dust after
all all this is not only for ukraine's
freedom but for europe's freedom we have
already been waiting for 31 days so who
is running the euro-atlantic community
is it still moscow because of their
threats
on sunday across ukraine prayers for
victory
and an end to the war
my mother is 68 she desperately wants to
go home she doesn't believe that the
home is not there anymore in our village
whole streets were destroyed by russian
tanks
after a month of russian bombs and
shelling not everyone is willing to turn
the other cheek
our military needs weapons because we
can't stop the war with diplomacy
diplomacy doesn't work
we don't know putin's reasons and we
cannot convince him by talking
i don't know his reasons but he is
against the whole world
in gerson protesters still being tear
gassed say demonstrations have pushed
russian forces back and they are not in
complete control of the city
in kharkiv more overnight shelling
further devastating a city already
heavily battered by russian strikes
and more evacuations from mariopol
still the worst affected city of the war
the latest attacks on levive came after
moscow announced plans to refocus its
military on the donbas region lev's
mayor and its residents
say the missile strikes are proof
russia cannot be trusted
you can still smell the fuel in the air
24 hours after russian missiles hit the
storage facility
just over there
pretty much destroying it completely now
this fuel depot the fire that was here
has been put out firefighters have
managed to make sure that the facility
is now safe and we have these large fuel
trucks here on site to transport the
rest of the fuel that is still at that
depot away from this area this is a
mixed residential industrial area and
that fuel needs to be removed from here
because this location is now considered
a known target
the facility is still standing but
structurally compromised
salvaging the remaining fuel is
important for the war effort
and for the safety of this neighborhood
one of the latest to be targeted in this
conflict
zayn vasravi al-jazeera leviev